prenez un héros sympa et trop bien sapés
sais quelle matière je sais pas mais en
tout cas ça gratte mettons lui dans les
pattes un dénommé fantasio et à mesure
non mais c'est pas un surnom ajoutons un
scientifique un peu farfelu comte de
champignac une belle histoire d'amour or
si toi et non c'était la gonflette
cottam je peux le faire aussi un ta
gueule l'écureuil globe trotter spip
spip.php spirou c'est comme moi n'ont du
coup et un échange très très méchant et
moi le patron c'est moi le patron je
serais pas inquiet complexe
d'infériorité ça le 21 février
préparez vous à une grande aventure est
encore raté tu as tu avais dit de les
chauffer quand ils sont à l'arrêt
on parle quand même une bonne équipe
tous les deux
[Musique]